it's an election like no other voter
volatility is the highest it's ever be
more and more people are willing to
switch parties an election taking place
next month anybody gonna be voting no
one's vote can be taken for granted any
other parties this election is taking
place against a backdrop of a bitterly
divided country loyalties the parties
have been torn apart by brexit they were
misled and it makes me very angry
it's time they're getting job it's not
very virus Johnson put it over voters
are now open to persuasion like never
before
[Music]
as campaigning kicks off
I've come to Warsaw an industrial town
where they've been making saddles since
the Middle Ages
people here voted overwhelmingly for
brexit and even elected a Conservative
MP in 2017 after nearly four decades of
labour dominance its towns like this
where the election will be won or lost
this deprived white working-class estate
was always labour but many here have
switched to the toys signalling an end
to longtime political allegiances Corbin
is itíd round wattle
his name is aidid well you can't go in
Pacific's but just an iron core being a
doll liking shopkeeper Trevor has gone
blue after being a lifelong red for him
Jeremy Corbyn is part of the problem a
lot of people in this area are
struggling to live struggling together
Jeremy Corbyn says he will reverse all
the cuts that the Tories have done in
the last 10 years
surely that's a good enough reason to
vote Labour we've aired all this before
and nothing's really changed I don't
think the people do you trust any any
people in Parliament's because their
lives have never changed under any any
year government but the same Breck siege
is a big chance in life even now now B
now is what the air come over actually
go
it's clear to see you bricks it is the
center of this election for Trevor this
is an area that has been hit hard by
years of Tory austerity and people here
should be voting labor but they're not
and it seems in some ways that Boris
Johnson is providing some sort of hope
for a life after brexit this is the most
difficult election that I've covered
exclusive analysis of the country's
demographics by Sky News his election
team has found that people's voting
habits are now less influenced by social
class and more than ever defined by
cultural factors indicated by age
education race and of course brexit
Walsall north is absolutely critical to
Boris Johnson's gamble at this general
election he needs to secure an overall
majority and not only does he have to
retain seasonal Walsall he has to win
over many other constituencies that did
vote lead in the EU referendum
saddlemaker Rey and his family have
already been won over she's got a real
flair for martin his wife who used to
vote labour is also behind him body's is
like what like when the lads isn't he
really weird yeah I think so yeah yes
he's one of the boys and he's mad racers
and stitches hundreds of leather saddles
in this tiny carriage he voted leave in
the EU referendum Boris is the best
option about and so see what goes on and
see what happens hopefully sticks to his
word and gets on with it I mean he said
you'd deliver brexit on the 31st of
October and that not he thought no he
would have done why not vote for the
brexit party if I thought fraud will get
in a wood but he won't get in boys
Johnson would be great if they could
both team up together I can't see that
happening
vorrei and other saddle makers in this
town brexit is the defining issue of
this election it is taking too long and
74% of people here including Peter voted
to exit the EU the second largest leave
vote in the country and had no surprise
he's frustrated with politicians
personally I voted out but I actually no
longer no longer care I can't be a state
the issue of bricks it is cutting across
traditional voting lines especially with
more parties to choose from but not
everyone is ready to abandon Jeremy
Corbyn dad was like a mum was live a
very strong labor paper Susan is a
former carer who is worried what impact
leaving the EU will have on our health
my choice is to stick with labour I've
got my shoes
our verdicts praxic thing and if we go
with Johnson we could lose an up a lot
medication is I on my list because I'm
diabetic Amazon is and we need to know
that we're gonna get our incident
the divisions caused by this election
are all too apparent there's no doubt to
Brick's it will be driving people to
vote but so to O leaders personalities
an election taking place next month well
you will be voting put your hands up for
the people it is leave a voting areas
like Warsaw that will be high on a
Tories target list in the coming weeks
but if Jeremy Corbyn wants to be Prime
Minister he will need to win big in
remain cities like Bristol even among
the middle classes a hundred miles south
of Austin along the m5 and across the
iconic a Clifton suspension bridge is
the Bristol West constituency a Labour
stronghold but one that is now
threatened by a pact between the Liberal
Democrats and the Greens Jeremy Corbyn
can rely on supporters like Jude who
voted to remain along with 79% of people
here the third highest in the country I
saw him on Saturday to rally speaking
and I was I got quite emotional actually
I was crying and so we're awful lot of
people around me and seeing someone like
him speak is emotional for you is it
yeah yeah yeah hugely emotional why do
you think people just don't trust to any
call me I don't know because I do
he has been undermined by people who
have a lot more money and a lot more
power than he has but I thought when you
go to working-class areas and speak to
people who were struggling to put food
on the table they don't be yeah you
didn't see your vision of what you see
at ome Corbett they didn't believe in
him they don't believe he is the man who
should be leading the Labour Party it's
a shame because he is he is absolutely
the man who should be leading the Labour
Party and when he gets in and starts
putting things right they will then
begin to see that's the corbin east of
you but Jude's vision of Jeremy Corbyn
is not shared among remain supporters
even her neighbors across the road is
former Labour supporter roof who has
gone green I voted to remain as did most
people in bris
the West and we've got to remain MP but
her views aren't being listened to by
the Labour Party so I don't think the
Labour Party can possibly represent
everybody and I think their message is
getting lost so they haven't been a
viable opposition for quite a long time
even here brexit has destabilized a
two-party system no seat is safe under
these conditions
voters are becoming more volatile
they're behaving more and more like
consumers and in a constituency such as
this where it voted heavily to remain
within the EU they will decide probably
on the day which is the party best place
to keep the UK within the EU and that
might not necessarily be the Labour
Party
that's because labour is facing
competition from the so called remain
alliance an electoral pact between the
Liberal Democrats pride Camry and the
Greens that will see candidates standing
aside in some constituencies despite the
Lib Dems being traditionally strong in
Bristol they will not challenge the seat
instead they will stand aside for the
Green Party to take on labor for the
remain vote I think it will rumble on
for years and maybe that's what the Lib
Dem said look why don't we just stop
this rethink some things but but don't
necessarily go that way but yeah maybe
it will be a relief to have it done but
I don't think it'll be the end of
talking about it and all the legal
ramifications will go on for years
young people are starting their voting
lives with less attachment to particular
parties than previous generations just
like these students forty-seven percent
of those here are graduates and they're
more likely to have voted remain another
dividing line which reflects how much
politics is changing but they know
they're going to get some people who
will say Jeremy Corbyn is on the fence
he's not clear he wants a second
referendum and that's not democratic
it's undemocratic to have a solid
position on brac set to say we will do
this all that is undemocratic you've got
to be open to people you know fulfilling
democracy and having their say having
their vote we've had what 10 years 10
years of austerity
you know Universal Credit I mean I've
met throughout families in low fairly
well-off places who are struggling it's
not a brexit only election and people
need to know that
their votes will matter the 2017
election saw more people switching
directly between the two big parties
than ever before politicians can't just
rely on past loyalties which is why
their message has to be clear there are
some people who believe that Jeremy
Corbyn doesn't have that real power he's
not strong enough as leader well is if
you believe that I know that Judah has
been a Labour supporter for over 40
years and says it's a 14% of ethnic
minorities who live in Bristol most are
back in Jeremy Corbyn our research shows
raises another cultural factor that
defines how people vote and wanting we
don't believe in this principle we
believe in short I believe in integrity
if you are demonstrating and straighten
that to us for support don't lie class
or majority of us we support Jeremy
Carville that's an absolute [ __ ] the
next Prime Minister will ultimately be
decided by voters in cities like Bristol
fighting to change the results of the EU
referendum so too will it be decided in
towns like also a place where brexit is
seen as a new dawn with the country in
the mix of one of the most unpredictable
election campaigns and decades the days
of people staying loyal to a single
political party over multiple elections
has become famous
grexit has turned this into a nation of
swing voters
fragmenting Ella politics